bro good evening everyone and welcome to
the executive this evening prior to
budget Council in at seven o'clock
um I'll just move through the agenda
paper so um could we note the Tendencies
and I have had apologies from councilor
Adele new are there any other apologies
that people are aware of
okay thank you and are there any
Declarations of Interest
no lovely right so moving on to item
three which is the land sales program
and if I pass over to councilor Patel
thank you
sorry I'm just struggling to get it up
actually
yeah if you got the paper there
[Music]
thank you
sorry thank you Tom um just to introduce
um as part of the ongoing
um Finance work that we prepare each
year we produce a program a strategic
Land review program and this is part one
um
where there's some chance within it with
some disposal
um notifications in it
some of which may be known some and have
been on the list for some years
um
any questions thank you thank you are
there any questions from the executive
any wider questions yeah councilor
whetton
um
I presume I need to not refer to any
Financial amounts when at this point
um but at the Jubilee Center
um St Mary's Road Bowden it's been an
issue for quite a few years
um about what quite is going to happen
on that site but there is a general
understanding going back quite some time
that a new community center will be
arise From the Ashes of the old one as
part of this
um but very little seems to be happening
in that respect and the Community
Association are getting concerned about
lack of consultation with themselves
um I have spoken to officers and it
doesn't really add much more to the
story than I'm saying now but it would
be good to
um get it clarified about a replacement
Community Center even if it's something
that's not
um not the same size as the existing
sting one and and get a an understanding
for the for the local residents and the
Community Association going forward
okay thank you councilor wetton
councilor Patel I'm happy to pick that
up with you after this meeting I'm
afraid I can't provide any more
Enlightenment on that in at this current
point but I'm happy to pick this up with
you
thank you and uh councilman as you
indicate
yes thank you leader could could I just
um ask a question on the table two
um land at pennybridge Lane Shore Road
in flixton
um it's a proposal for um a residential
scheme for homeless people what what
would the time frame be for
consultations and
um for a decision to be made
councilor Patel
I just had in my inbox uh the next date
for an imminent public consultation on
that and I will provide details of that
um shortly
thank you and councilor Jerome
thank you leader I just wanted to
quickly ask about um table two also and
the um stoko Avenue Altrincham plan I
just that has been rumbling on for
around about 10 years so it is actually
good to see the council finally moving
forward with it was ahead of steam I
just wondered if there's any date for
when a likely planning application would
be submitted
councilor Patel apologies again I don't
have that information
um this type of work takes some
considerable time in the planning as I'm
sure you appreciate and the team that
deals with it
um a small but dedicated and we we have
a number of key projects in the pipeline
currently
um but I appreciate there's an appetite
for the for residents and members to
understand more so I'm happy to pick
this up after the meeting
brilliant thank you very much for that
um so there's no further questions
um are we happy to agree the
recommendations as set out in the paper
thank you very much okay moving on to
agenda item four which is the
executive's final Revenue budget
proposals for 23 24 and the medium-term
financial strategy 25 26 to 26 27 as is
tradition I think the main conversation
discussion debate will take place in the
council chamber in a little under an
hour so I was just going to ask are
there any questions or comments from the
executive councilor Patel thank you I
realize
um the tradition is uh that we do wait
for Council but I just wanted to say
that I'm proud to support this budget
and we'll do so later at Council this
has been the third budget in which I've
been involved with as an executive
member and I can say that such is the
level of responsibility and the weight
of the knowledge that our decisions
impacts on the lives of our accidents
it's a process that presents me with
great personal and professional
Challenge and I know that this challenge
is phase two by my colleagues and our
officers and you all right to it very
diligently and with great
professionalism and I'd like to offer my
sincere thanks to you all these budget
pressures never let off and the work has
already started on next year's budget
and it's a huge responsibility that we
all take really seriously
there are lots lots of positives here
but it pains me that inflationary
pressures have derailed the year's
ongoing budgetary works so significantly
and a period of stability for local
government Finance as well overdue
I couldn't have put it any more
eloquently myself uh thank you councilor
Patel for that comment are there any
other questions from the executive or
wider
okay so we are asked an exec to agree
recommendations a to X in this agenda
item and also refer recommendations y to
DD for Council to note all those in
favor
thank you moving on to item number five
which is the capital strategy asset
investment strategic Capital project
program and Prudential and local
indicators 2023 to 2026 again this will
come up largely in the council meeting
to follow are there any questions or
comments from the executive in the
meantime
any wider questions or comments
yes John's come forward thank you
Council choking
uh thank you
um mainly so I don't take up time in the
next meeting I just want to say thank
you
um it's very difficult budget but thanks
for finding the money to resurface hail
Road and for Stanford Park uh some
repairs on the new fence there it's
going to be very very much appreciated
by the residents so just just thanks for
that thank you very much for that that's
much much appreciated are there any
other questions or comments no okay so
I'm asking executive to approve
recommendations one to eight on the
agenda papers for this item or those in
favor
brilliant
so item number six
is the treasury management strategy 2023
24 to 2025 26. likewise I know I'm going
to be touching on this in the uh council
meeting very shortly but in the meantime
are there any questions or comments from
members of the executive
any wider questions or comments
no okay well for this one we're asking
the executive to note the report and
recommend it to council or those in
favor
lovely okay um item number seven is fees
and charges for 23 24.
um again this can be touched upon in the
budget council meeting itself are there
any questions or comments from executive
colleagues
any wider questions or comments
okay well I'm asking the executive to
refer the recommendation set out in the
papers to council for approval all those
in favor
okay
um item number eight is the executive's
response to the scrutiny committee's
recommendations to the budget proposals
for 2023-24 I know I have previously
referenced my thanks in this um this
forum for the um the ongoing work and
challenge that the scrutiny scrutiny
committee councilors provide as part of
the budget process and I hope that I
hope that the committee are happy with
the response that we provided in
response to your report um are there any
first of all any questions or comments
from the executive
okay any wider comments I think
counselor Acton you're looking to speak
just very briefly uh chair
um I'm pleased about the response from
the executive
um I think there are 12 recommendations
uh that we put to the executive and I
think uh it's accepted by uh the
executive and I think
um it will take a lot of monitoring
throughout the year for the three
scrutiny committees to make sure that
the budget is delivered in the way that
it's presented so thank you
thank you and I know that as we look
ahead dependent on on things on the
horizon we will continue that dialogue
with scrutiny and with counselors
because I think it's so important for us
all to work together in these
challenging Financial Times Are there
any other further comments
okay so we're asking the executive to
approve our response to the scrutiny
committee or those in favor
thank you right there is no urgent
business but we do have a an exclusion
resolution to move which I will try and
read a bit more eloquently than I did at
the last meeting before we turn off the
the cameras so the motion is that the
public be excluded from this meeting
during consideration of the remaining
items on the agenda because of the
likelihood of disclosure of exempt
information which Falls within one or
more descriptive category or categories
of the Local Government Act 1972
schedule 12a as amended by the local
government access to information
variation order 2006 and specified on
the agenda item or report relating to
such item respectively okay and then if
Alex confirms
okay and have the public been